marketing market marketing marketing
marketing marketing marketing market
marketing Martin well I mean I also
think funds should come in to marketing
and they be that there was a an occasion
where British Airways decided to sponsor
the a giant wheel opposite the houses of
Commons in London England and and this
giant wheel was lying flat on the ground
and they got all the press together one
morning where they were going to lift
the wheel up and I got a call at about
7:00 in the morning say that saying that
BA had technical problems and they
couldn't get the wheel up and all the
press the world's press were there
waiting we had an airship company so I
rang up the airship company and we
scrambled an airship and and the airship
went right over the wheel and it had a
massive big banner across it which
simply said ba can't get it up and
anyway we got more coverage around the
world for that and I think any any other
one single thing we've done on marketing
generally I mean again I think that that
the cheapest form of marketing is not
full-page adverts in the press it's it's
free advertising so if you're up against
a big corporation you do need to use
yourself to try to get free advertising
and do try to do it in fun ways like
that so you stand out from the crowd try
to make sure you you know you end up
doing something that hits the front page
of the newspapers rather than the back
page and but you know you but and you
know obviously we've gone to extreme
lengths to try to you know put virgin on
the map you know whether it's trying to
be the first across the Atlantic in a
hot-air balloon or the Pacific in a
hot-air balloon or and you know but and
you know but it but it did help I think
you know great the Virgin brand make it
a fun brand and and a brand that people
could identify with take time to study
good direct respond
take time to for instance maybe develop
a swipe file so one of the things that I
did four years is any time I bought
something I would identify the ad the
phone call the print ad the the offer
whatever it was that made me decide to
buy it and I would either cut it out or
record it put it into Evernote whatever
it might be and save it so I had a
record of everything that I bought and
why I bought it and then I could go back
and review it and I'd be like oh looks
like I fell for this this and this not
the bad way it looks like this tipped me
from or not interested - yeah I'll spend
five fifty five hundred five thousand
dollars on that yeah I save all that
everything that works in sales has been
done already you do not need to reinvent
the wheel so just keep track of the crap
that you buy or the awesome stuff that
you buy and decide what was the trigger
what push me over the edge and then just
sell the people like you that's what I
do it's really easy
people are like who's your market I
might well you know I'm a 30-something
asset-based tech savvy male so why don't
I just solve those people and it's a lot
easier than trying to guess so let me
tell you about my introduction of
network marketing because I had a very
close mind to it since I can build my
own businesses I said why do I need a
network marketing business but about 15
years ago I have a good friend his name
is Bill and this guy is the best real
estate investor I know he has tons of
assets in here so I said bill why did
you start a network marketing business
and his simple sense was very simple he
says it's my way of helping people but
more importantly he says the reason most
people can't invest in real estate is
because they don't have a business they
don't make enough money simply because
taxes debt inflation and retirement
savings are killing them they cannot
even invest so my friend bill who was a
professional real estate entrepreneur he
says I started a network marketing
business so the people that worked with
me could start their own business and
then invest money with him so with that
I realized then that network marketing
wasn't about making money but it was
about helping people to hell
other people make money so they become
financially free so the beauty of
network marketing I said like it's very
low entry point doesn't take much money
you can do it part-time and where you
profit is in most big corporations is
they spend millions sometimes billions
of dollars in advertising so runners
give that money to advertisers Network
market depends on building a network is
called word of mouth like you recommend
a movie to a best friend
so really the reason I support network
marketing because it's not about selling
it's about people helping people build
assets in the asset columns becoming
business owners and then becoming
investors but I believe very strongly
that we could build a different kind of
company I never believed never I think
it would have been arrogant to believe
that we could have a thousand 2,000 or
7,500 stores in the US and around the
world but something really magical
started happening and it started
happening as a result of not advertising
or conventional consumer classical
marketing the fact is that Starbucks
spends very little on traditional
advertising it started happening because
we demonstrated to ourselves and now the
world that to build an enduring
sustainable long-term business and
consumer brand it's not about fancy
marketing it's about establishing a very
powerful and unusual emotional
relationship with the customer so our
whole philosophy is let's take most of
the money that we would have spent on
paid advertising or paid marketing and
rather than buy our exposure instead
let's invest it into customer service
and the customer experience and let our
customers do the marketing for us
through word-of-mouth
on any given day about 75% of our orders
are from repeat customers and we
basically grew from no sales in 1999 to
in 2008 was the first year where we hit
a billion dollars in gross merchandise
sales and actually even despite the bad
economy we've actually continued to grow
over the last two years in fact our net
sales we're q1 this year we're up almost
50
percent year-over-year and people ask us
what do we do differently over the last
24 months and it's actually we actually
didn't do anything differently and it's
not because of anything we did over the
past two years it's because of all the
investment we made prior to that that we
continue to grow because of the loyalty
of our customers and the number one
driver of all that growth is through
repeat customers and word-of-mouth and
but PayPal is really a case of of where
the whole viral marketing it's really a
perfect case example of viral marketing
like hotmail was where one one one
customer would essentially act as a
salesperson for you for all the bringing
and other customers so they would send
money to a friend and essentially
recruit that friend into the network and
so you had this exponential growth the
more customers you have the faster it
grew so you like bacteria in a petri
dish it just goes like does this S curve
and in fact I ran PayPal for about the
first two years of its existence and we
launched after year one and by the end
of year two we had a million customers
so gives you an exact you know to could
you sense for how fast things things
grow in that scenario we were and we
didn't have a Salesforce where we
actually didn't have VP of Sales we
didn't have a VP of Marketing and we
didn't spend any money on advertising
most people think marketing is a task
neither science nor an art it's a task
where someone gives you an average
product for average people and your job
is to hype it and spin it and promote it
and advertise it so that the masses will
buy and I'm not buying that I think that
marketing is the art of making something
that people want to talk about of
producing something that people want to
engage in so marketers have to move
upstream now we have to stop being the
last step in the process and start being
the first step for starting as we know
we have a darn good product but if we
take the time with ourselves and our
staff to go in there and tell them all
the ways to use it and reassure them not
only a good product
here's how you use it to create a good
salon experience or the consumer when
you take it home to keep your hair the
same in between visits you fill a need
in the marketplace one there's the need
of course to buy a product or another
product but the next one is you must
constantly remind them how to use it
properly which makes you a little
different now granted maybe there's
another one use the same way but nobody
told them we're amazing times when
people are using some of our finest
products and didn't know there's other
ways to use it also it's through
education must constantly reinforce the
education why it's so good that's the
thing right like you said you know a lot
of artists just have MySpace and just
have you know a couple songs and don't
have them what website don't have
marketing don't have anything and then
they get disappointed when they only
sell like 70 records you know and it's
like you got to understand that this is
about marketing like this whole thing is
about marketing it's about your image
it's about your story you got to be
appealing to people and if you're going
to release a record in Canada you have
to do something that nobody else has
done or else there's no point that's how
I see it to me marketing is about values
this is a very complicated world it's a
very noisy world and we're not going to
get a chance to get people to remember
much about us no company is and so we
have to be really clear on what we want
them to know about us now appala
fortunately is one of the half-a-dozen
best brands in the whole world right up
there with Nike Disney Coke Sony it is
one of the greats of the greats not just
in this country but all around the globe
and but even a great brand needs
investment and caring if it's going to
retain its relevance and vitality and
the Apple brand has clearly suffered
from neglect in this area in the last
few years and we need to bring it back
the way to do that
is not to talk about speeds and Z's it's
not to talk about MIPS and megahertz
it's not to talk about why you're better
than Windows the dairy industry tried
for 20 years to convince you that milk
was good for you the lie but they tried
anyway and the sales were going like
this and then they tried got milk and
the sales are going like this God not
the thing to talk about apart method
that focuses on the absence of the
product but but but the best example of
all and and one of the greatest jobs of
of marketing and though if the universe
has ever seen is Nike remember Nike
sells a commodity they sell shoes and
yet when you think of Nike you feel
something different than a shoe company
and their ads as you know they don't
ever talk about the closet they don't
ever tell you about their soils and
weather better than Reebok their souls
with Nike doing their advertising they
they honor great athletes and they honor
great athletics that's who they are
that's what they are about Apple spend a
fortune on advertising you'd never know
it you've never known so when I got here
you appaled aspired their agency we're
doing a competition with 23 agencies
that you know for news remember pick one
and we blew that up and we we hired
Shaddai the idea j'en see that I was
fortunate to work with years ago we
created some award-winning work
including the commercial voted the best
Adam of May of 1984 by advertising
professionals and we started working
about eight weeks ago and what was the
question they asked was our customers
want to know who is Apple and what is it
that we stand for where do we fit in
this world and
what we're about isn't making boxes for
people to get their job done although we
do that well we do that better than
almost anybody in some cases but apples
about something more than that Apple at
the core its core value is that we
believe that people his passion can
change the world for the better
that's what we believe and we have the
opportunity to work with people like
that we've had an opportunity work with
people like you with software developers
with customers who have done it in some
big and some small ways and we believe
that in this world people can change it
for the better and that those people
that are crazy enough to think they can
change the world are the ones that
actually do and so what we're going to
do in our first brand marketing campaign
in several years is to is to get back to
that core value a lot of things have
changed the markets a totally different
place than it was a decade ago and
apples totally different in Apple's
placing it it's totally different and
believe me the products and the
distribution strategy and manufacturing
are totally different and we understand
that but values and core values those
things shouldn't change the things that
Apple believed in at its core are the
same things that Apple really stands for
today and so we wanted to find a way to
communicate this and what we have is
something that I am I'm very moved by it
honors those people who have changed the
world some of them are living some of
them are not
but the ones that aren't as you'll see
you know that if they ever use the
computer it would have been maxed and
the theme of the campaign is think
difference if the people honoring the
people who think difference and who made
this world forward and it's it is what
we are about it touches the soil of this
company so I'm gonna go ahead and roll
it and I hope that you feel the same way
about it I do years to the crazy ones
misfits rebels troublemakers round pegs
in the square holes
once you can see things
then I found who
they have no respect in status quo you
can quote them disagree with them
glorify or vilify them about the only
thing you can't do
they change things human race forward
and while some may see them as the crazy
ones we see genius because the people
who are crazy enough to think they can
change the world the ones who do
thank you so much for watching let us
know which of the clips you found most
interesting by leaving a comment below
that's it
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon